la pandemia pesa sobre la economía pero
el presidente francés asegura que
también motivó al país a reconstruir su
industria
debemos revertir los términos de una
dependencia productiva francesa y
europea
macrón afirma que el comité evidenció la
alta dependencia francesa de terceros
países para revertir la situación y
financiar el desarrollo de industrias
tecnológicas innovadoras y francesas el
presidente presentó un proyecto de
30.000 millones de euros para los
próximos cinco años
innovación y la innovación es una fuente
de soluciones para vivir mejor para
proyectar una nación un continente
quizás el evento entero de solución
quizá un banco límite para buscar
soluciones que son buenas para toda la
humanidad sin embargo los aspectos de la
innovación en el mundo en el que vivimos
está cambiando y tiene un jefe soft
hamptons macrón explicó que francia no
volverá a lo que llamó industrias del
ayer sino que se centrará en nuevas
tecnologías des carbonizadas como
vehículos eléctricos el presidente
francés reivindico su voluntad de
convertir al país en líder mundial de
producción de hidrógeno verde y de
continuar invirtiendo en energía no con
los grandes reactores que ha
desarrollado en los últimos años y que
han resultado más caros de lo previsto
sino en mini plantas nucleares que
producen menos energía pero son más
fácil de construir y son más seguras de
las que posee el país en la actualidad
la hoja de ruta llamada francia 2030
llega después del plan de 100 mil
millones de euros presentado el año
pasado para recuperar la economía
francesa
los críticos cuestionan los tiempos
elegidos para presentar el plan
quinquenal seis meses antes de las
elecciones presidenciales francesas
prometiendo gasto masivo para atraer a
los votantes de cara a preparar su
reelección